willkommen beim Tuesday Talk eurem neuen
dienstagsunterhaltungspodcast dieser
Podcast wird euer Leben verändern du
hast halt andere Qualitäten das H sich
richtig schlimm an ich meine das gar
nicht böse Social Media Menschen unter
sich behind the scenes da geht's ja auch
noch mal richtig ab das Ausnutzen werden
nä Zeit we das ist richtig Psychopathen
krankes Zukunft des Todes ein Mädchen
das in meine Richtung gehalten und mich
heimlich gefilmt hat die Gesellschaft
ist einfach nur getrmt auf gratis hast
du schon mal überhaupt gesehen dass ein
influencer bezahlt worden ist von SAR du
kannst gar nicht in mich reingucken ich
im Hotelzimmer immer abends geheult aber
die Leute sehen nur bei Instagram ey Bo
voll Spaß der Tuesday Talk ist übrigens
ein videoopodcast ihr könnt uns also
sehen oder auch nur hören überall da wo
es Podcasts gibt und jeden Dienstag 0
Uhr sind wir für euch ready ihr könnt
uns nur nicht schmecken